many nations have different
interpretations of shared historical
moments this discrepancy in how history
is viewed by two opposing sides is
pretty clear with respect to the 1688
Glorious Revolution in Britain it is
mostly seen as British nobleman
overthrowing a tyrannical King and
replacing him with a constitutional
monarch whereas in the Netherlands it's
seen as that time we conquered Britain
and Ireland so who is correct was it a
case of the British Isles being brought
to heel by the Dutch or the English
inviting a foreigner to bring an end to
its own disorder before getting into too
much detail here's a brief overview of
events in the year 1660 England Scotland
and Ireland had restored its monarchy
after a period of republicanism under
Oliver Cromwell the returned king
charles ii had his own problems during
his reign but the worst thing he did was
in 1685 when he died charles had
converted to catholicism on his deathbed
and had no children
thus the throne had passed to his
brother James who was already a Catholic
not something Protestant England was
very keen on James upon becoming King
promised to respect the religious
institutions of England but fun fact no
the English nobility whilst unhappy with
James weren't too concerned because he
was getting all a bit and also had no
heirs until 1688 when he did onto the
scene comes William of Orange the
Protestant stat holder of the Dutch
Republic and not to be confused with his
great-grandfather William the silent
also known as William of Orange
William was also concerned about having
yet another opponent in Europe Plus
since he was married to James's daughter
Mary he did have a claim to the English
throne
William was willing to act we wanted to
be sure that he would get some support
from the nobles to his rescue came a
group of leading noblemen who promised
their support and with that he came on
over bringing with him 15,000 troops and
a fleet larger than the Spanish Armada
when he got their support for James
basically evaporated instantly and
having lost his army to desertion he
opted to run away to France after this
it was argued that running away was
tantamount to abdicating and so William
Ameri were made joint monarchs of
England Scotland and Ireland in 1689 the
condition was that William except that
he ruled as a constitutional monarch and
that his power had its limits
Britain's modern form of monarchy was
born so the interpretations of the
Glorious Revolution are of course very
different the English version of events
is that since William refused to come
over without the support of some noble
laws that this wasn't an invasion but
instead a Dutch backed English coup this
position is supported by the fact that
William despite his leading of the
troops wasn't made king in his own right
but was given
equal Authority with Mary also William
had to agree to the 1689 Bill of Rights
which limited his power as king which is
not exactly something a conqueror would
accept as such since the Dutch were also
Protestants it's argued that it was a
mutually beneficial deal that
strengthened the Protestant world as for
the Dutch interpretation it's mostly
seen as a conquest or at the very least
a coup that would have failed without
them the evidence they used to support
this claim is the fact that William
didn't land to a ground welcomed by the
Lord's but landed with an army of 15,000
Dutchman and was backed by an armada the
Dutch position is seen through the lens
of William being an intelligent
strategist he saw the turmoil in England
Scotland and Ireland as an opportunity
the Netherlands were surrounded by
foreign enemies who saw its existence as
a threat one argument is that it was the
Dutch not the English who directed
events threatened by foreign invasion
William needed to strengthen his hand
and so appealed to disaffected Lords in
Britain to rebel turmoil in the British
Isles offered a rich opportunity for
Williams since Englishmen in English
money would strengthen the Dutch
position it's argued that whilst William
did want support from the nobility this
was largely a formality in the his
position meant that invading was a risky
DIF taken anyway since the pros outweigh
the cons it wasn't a crown he
necessarily needed it was the combined
wealth of the Dutch Republic in the
kingdom of England Scotland and Ireland
to fight the coming Wars with his
Catholic rivals William got what he
wanted but also so did the Protestant
majority in England which is what makes
this debate so interesting did the Dutch
conquer England well they turned up with
an army but faced little resistance and
many in England were content to allow
William and Mary to rule in the end
little force was used to gain England
but a great deal was needed to subdue
Scotland and Ireland which is why for
many the Glorious Revolution is both a
conquest and a coup I hope you enjoyed
this episode and thank you for watching
with extra thanks to my patrons that you
see on screen now and a special thanks
to James Bissonnette ozark a flash mark
H party-boy Co David archaeologist Rob
Waterhouse Chris wicker Michael Reynolds
Gustav Swan onion duck
David Silverman Paul Maggie packs Kowski
Winston Heyward vasily our vedas
christian check' anthony Beckett Skye
Chappell Adam Harvey and Ike